Let's be honest, your contribution to
the world so far is a browser history
you make sure no one sees. Incognito
tabs, deleted logs, hours gone, nothing
built. Now, contrast that with this. A
masjid is being completed in a village
in Norway where Muslims have nothing. It
will stand for generations. Those who
donate will be remembered by Allah. And
those who don't will quietly return to
the shadows, back to the consumption,
secrecy, and absolute nothing to show
for it. So, [music] do the right thing.
Post the video or click the link below
and donate for your own akhira.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. How are you guys doing? And
welcome to another episode where I'm
joined with the esteemed Saboor Ahmed.
How are you? Alhamdulillah.
>> Good to meet you, man. It's uh been a
long time since we've done a reaction
video. And the person that we're going
to be doing a reaction video
against is Oh, not against, but about
really is Alex O'Connor. He's an atheist
theologian
uh who we both had debates with in the
past. I think some maybe 5 years ago,
something like that. The one that you
had went viral. Clips of it went uh mega
viral, actually. And the one that I had
is probably one of the most viewed
debates he's ever participated in. Uh
about 5 million, I think, or four or
five. Like, I don't know what it is. On
my channel alone, not including his
channel and the other channels that it
was translated into cuz it was
translated into many different
languages. And it was in the University
of Oxford and the Oxford Forum.
Uh an interesting uh debate. It was a
two on two.
Uh but that's something that people can
watch in their own time. Alex O'Connor
uh what intrigued me about him is he
didn't really follow the line of the new
atheists and the braggadocious sort of
overconfident, strident nature of the
the atheist movement. And he had more of
a refined, yeah, sort of uh branding.
Um but I was wondering what his position
on the Palestine genocide was.
And this is the video that I saw. Let's
take a look at that and respond in kind.
Free free Palestine. Free free Palestine
over and over again. And
and and it's just sort of it's just sort
of a slogan. Uh and and and I I get that
it like in that in that circumstance, I
get why that's useful because it's sort
of a shorthand for for saying
"Here we are. We're making noise. Be
aware that we exist and that we believe
this thing that's that's
antithetical to to what you're saying."
But if you were to pull one of them away
and say, "What's your position?" And
they just said, "Free Palestine." And
you said, "What does that mean? What
what what what do you mean?" And they're
just like, "I It just means, you know,
free Palestine." And that and that's it.
And there's no more depth. You'd be
like,
"I don't even understand what your
position is here." But that's what
happens all the time with something like
my body, my choice, you know? Well, I'll
tell you what, Sabour. Uh before we get
you to chime in on this, yeah. I want
you to also see something else that he
said because I've
seen clips of his here and there since
I've debated him. And one of the clips
that I was privy to was the following.
This is him talking about the genocide
in the Old Testament. Let's take a look
at what he says here and come back and
respond as well. So do I get sick to
death of people hand-waving away this
genocide by some vague reference to the
fact that Jesus came along to do
something which somehow kind of undoes
the immorality of it. Now, as you can
see, Sabour, he's very he's very angry.
He's very angry about the Bible's
endorsement of genocide.
Uh a genocide that probably took place
thousands of years ago.
Um where population sizes weren't
anything like the population sizes they
are today.
And where,
you know, it wouldn't have been 100,000
people that have been killed like the
Palestinian genocide. So he's talking
about an ancient genocide.
Something that happened thousands of
years ago. Yet, he's living
where in a time where the most important
genocide of our time, the Palestine
genocide,
is taking place, and he's not said a
word about that. And here he's making
fun, as we saw in the first clip, of the
Palestinian protesters, essentially
labeling them all as some kind of
ignoramuses who don't know anything
about what this phrase free Palestine
mean
means as if it's some kind of encoded
and philosophical language. We need this
man here to come
uh and teach us what it is. Yeah, I
mean, he's acting a bit like Peterson
here saying, "Well, what do they exactly
mean by this?" So, here's some things to
keep into context.
We have a genocide, a genocide that is
very clearly being sanctioned by the
very biblical verses that you are aware
of.
And that he repudiates. Yeah. And
something that you raised with William
Lane Craig and others. Okay, so you're
aware there is a live genocide being
live-streamed, and there's pictures and
videos everywhere that nobody can deny.
And you have already a reason to call
out genocide because of those biblical
verses and the fact that people believe
them to be from God. So, now you have a
live case study proving your very point,
but
the victims happen to be Muslim, and the
perpetrators are the Zionists in this
case. So, if it was the other way
around, I'm sure there would be this
moral rage from all of the new atheists,
including, you know, Dawkins and all the
all the rest of these guys, including
people like Alex O'Connor and others who
would be saying, "Look at this and this
terrible war and all this massacre and
all the Quranic verses which are
sanctioning this genocide." But now it's
actually
the biblical verses being used against
the Muslim population. Not only, and
this is what I found really um,
disappointing about Alex because
you know, my approach with him was
different to yours. Let's be frank about
that, right? And one of the things that
he kept repeating in the debate is about
moral consistency. Where is the moral
consistency here? You've spoken about
the historical genocide. You've seen a
live genocide. You've seen the same
biblical verses being used and the same
terms, Amalekites, being used for the
Palestinians to dehumanize them, which
is the first step in genocide. And yet,
the only thing you have to say about
Palestine is about why their
sloganeering is misleading or is
misunderstood or the protesters are low
low-tier IQ people who don't know what
they're saying. Like, that's the only
thing you've said. I I mean, And he's
actually speaking to to a Zionist who
promotes this genocide and who has been
>> And who has justified killing, by the
way.
>> Yeah, who defends it and actually has
justified collective punishment, Andrew
Gold. And we've made a separate reaction
video about him with his conversation
with Stephen Law. And he knows that
that's his position and instead of being
as forceful as he was with whoever it
was, William Lane Craig or Dinesh,
whoever the person
that he was speaking with, the
Christians, when it comes to religion,
he instead of being as forceful and
interrogative, you see, as as he was in
those contexts, here he is
essentially um,
like a mouse, sorry to say, an absolute
mouse. Somebody who's
afraid, who's scared, who is controlled
by narratives and people. And this
reminds me of the famous quote that if
you want to see who who rules over you,
then see who you are not allowed to
criticize. Yeah. It's very clear to us
now. Thank you for showing us that
you're just an extension, a
materialistic extension of your new
atheist predecessors. You're nothing
different. The only thing different is
your disposition and your demeanor. I
can see through that. Maybe some other
people can't see through that.
Um, I will tell you that some people,
because of his demeanor and sort of, you
know, quiet and calm and these kind of
things and they fall for the trap of
thinking that he's
well-intentioned. He's not a
well-intentioned guy. A person who
is this morally inconsistent, talking
about a genocide that took
place thousands of years ago, but
doesn't even want to speak about the
Palestinian genocide. There's no doubt.
Well, what makes me even more
disappointed in this situation is that
I've seen him live in a very passionate
way speak about human rights and also
the rights of animals.
>> Oh, yes.
>> we're going to speak wasn't he a vegan
or something like this?
>> Yeah, and he's a obviously a a vegan a
vegan activist.
>> he was a vegan, so you're talking about
So, here we talk about dogs. So, here we
talk about cats and dogs and mice.
Which you can
relate to being a mouse yourself. An
intellectual mouse. A moral mouse,
frankly. That's what he is. He's a moral
mouse because he can't come out and
speak and interrogate in one context he
can and in another context he can't.
But, you you can you can talk about
these animals, you see. You can talk
about these animals, huh?
And how it's you can't bear to see the
suffering or whatever it may be that led
you to veganism of all of all things.
But, you have a live as you mentioned,
well put.
Live stream people being killed and
stuff like that and
you got nothing to say. Babies babies
being incinerated, babies being
decapitated, a holocaust taking place,
burning happening. Oh, I I've got to he
keep quiet with this one because And and
only and only only talk about the
protesters. Only talk about the
protesters and I'll tell you something,
um hijab, right?
I had a different view of him to you and
we discussed this in the past. Let's
let's not mince our words, but I was
thoroughly disappointed when I saw this
cuz I was like, okay, you're not going
to say anything about Zionists, you're
not going to say this cuz you want to
be, you know, still have the ability to
be online without any hindrance. Okay,
fine. That's a stance that some people
take and they're worried about the
Zionists. But now you're actively
engaging with a Zionist host and you are
taking potshots at people who are
morally outraged and you're questioning
whether they even understand what free
Palestine means. That's the only
contribution you've made to this
narrative.
>> of the Bible
that took a genocide that took place
thousands He's so angry. He needs to get
it off his chest. He needs to put this
man in his place. He needs to talk about
this to William Lane Craig. He's using
it as a Look, this shows you with all
due respect that this false moral high
ground that's taken by these people,
right? Has now crumbled. We are We
understand exactly politics is the great
revealer, bro.
Yeah. It makes us see even within our
own community. Like I'm not even just
going to say with this guy. I mean it's
with
within our own community. I have
scholars who have stayed silent. Not
just that, some of them will be
persecuted physically if they don't if
they say something. We give them some
some sort of excuse. But some of them
who have had this forked tongue speaking
about this matter. And even some of them
talking about normalization
with the state of Israel.
Those people have been thoroughly
refuted or thoroughly exposed now. This
situation [snorts] has exposed people.
Mhm.
And that's why, you know, subhanallah,
we have to as Muslims see
we have to see that the community that's
going to care about the most
about us the most is our own community.
And when people like this
you know, who who now alhamdulillah
actually to be fair, he hasn't attacked
the Muslim community or Islam for a very
long time ever since the debate that
took place.
Well, actually academically attacking
Islam is not an issue. But morally
>> it is I mean it's good that he hasn't
done that. I'm happy that he hasn't done
that. I mean I'm not going to encourage
him to attack Islam. But of course of
course but academic critique is
different to the fact that you are now
aiding directly the enemies of Islam
while the genocide is still going on cuz
people are you know thinking it's not
going on. And if anything cuz look, you
have different levels in terms of how
Zionism is aided. One is the direct open
Zionist who's going to say we support
Zionism. There's others who are going to
say to the Palestinian protesters, these
people are low IQ people. We need to
basically ban the protesters. We need to
do this. You are part of the circle of
the Zionist uh medium machine to
basically make these people seem like
they don't know what they're talking
about. So, you are basically in the camp
of the Zionist. So, the
real question
>> question is is has he been paid by them?
I'm sorry to put it this way. It's the
question that we have to ask.
Now is have you been paid by them? So,
have you been paid by these individuals
to stay silent and to say these things
here and there?
Hm?
As a left-wing vegan activist, we know
left-wing people
uh have been uh
typically, all right, and conventionally
pro-Palestine.
As a left-wing atheist vegan,
you know, supporting of all these kind
of minority rights or at least on paper,
seeing a genocide, have you been paid?
Well, that's something you're going to
have to answer yourself. And I don't
want to waste any more time with this.
But I just wanted this to be something I
think we we need to be aware of because
when these people then moralize to us,
okay, it just becomes ridiculous, to be
honest. It is pathetic. I expected
better. I'll be very honest All right,
but why though? I mean No, look, I'll be
honest with you. I expected better and I
was like something like this for me is
making me think maybe I judged a person
by Their demeanor. Their demeanor. No,
only their demeanor but also sometimes,
you know, we have to keep this in mind
that
we you said it best, politics brings out
the truth. It brings out what's really
going on. Palestine has become a Furqan.
It's become a criterion that people have
shown their true colors and people have
shown the people of
uh you know who really care about human
rights and those people who pay lip
service until the time of truth comes
and then they are just silent.
With that we will conclude with salaam
alaikum warahmatullah wabarakatuh. You
probably don't deserve to watch this
video. Your level is honestly too low to
watch this video. So feel free to click
away from the video. But for the few who
can handle responsibility, we're
building the only masjid in a village in
Norway. First payment is already done.
Final 500,000 remaining. Huge sadaqa
jariya waiting. If you're serious about
Islam, you'll pause [music] the video
and you'll click the link below to
donate right now. If not, enjoy the
comment section.